how's it going bro
my name is and if I as you can see I
have this bonus man I have all these
items I spent a lot of time collecting
those it was not very fun but I hope
it's worth it yes here we are with the
final map the secret map it was it just
showed up like BAM
it's called curse house it's from the
movie and I don't know if you're
familiar with the movie but it's all as
this house and anyone who I don't like
that and it looks exactly like the one
in the movie and my arm is really we are
looking but that's ok this is supposed
to be the scariest one so I have my hope
shop boys and girls anyone who enters or
I have anything to do with the house
dies I don't why I'm doing it like this
but in the movies at least so yeah I get
the feeling going in here it's a bad
idea really bad idea and I don't know
exactly why I'm doing it alright
we're not going very well for era oh
come on
oh no already alright we're dead we're
dead weird I don't know why I'm laughing
all that stupid dog again wait who was a
creepy woman mom dad can no one's
picking up what the hell is going out
everyone Hales going down and wonder
what that reference brofist to you and
Rick yeah we're back is Erica if you
remember the first chapter we played as
Erica and our stupid [ __ ] dog ran
into a factory and and now we're in
happening oh no it's a phone call
somewhere
it sounds like it's coming from here
alright it's going in oh it's locked
[ __ ] great
it's good okay oh no it's hair I'm
everywhere here disgusting stuff I don't
know where to go this is so weird
me what I opened this door why did he
Wow I don't like that
hello alright weekend we're [ __ ] good
I'm sorry that the controls aren't very
good but I tried a lot of times to fix
it oh no this is the bathtub where oh no
this is where the little kid got
strangled along with his kid cat there's
your hair in it that's disgusting
someone has a lot of pubic hair
don't look down girl oh I know
oh now you're so stupid dammit oh Jesus
Christ
alright listen learn today here kids
don't look in
Harry bathtubs alright hi no it's cool
it's cool it's cool
they have soap at least I would wash my
face after that she's gusting can we
answer this [ __ ] phone now Oh No
hello anyone there I would have been so
[ __ ] scared if I was in this house
alone I would have found something that
doors locked and when I opened this door
i just opened the other one's really
weird let's just say you stayed see if
we can open it all right it's clicking
once again that's there alright fine
let's go upstairs then yeah yeah up
[ __ ] stairs see you in a couple hours
haha hey what happened he someone made a
mess I like it when it's clean and tidy
this apartment is [ __ ] small makes it
hard for me to turn running out of
batteries - that's too bad things in one
sentence I think maybe here's the stairs
let's go
I'm not pumped but let's go anyway
alright hello
why am I going out here's something
so I'm vaping is a kitty cat [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] kitty cats
I'll never understand
every time in movies when they go
upstairs I [ __ ] die why am I going
upstairs all right fine let's shake this
door I guess I need batteries or
something I shut up kid can I get him to
stop of you hello it's 2:00 in the
[ __ ] morning it's not a good hour to
be in a spooky house there's been better
hours for spooky house shut up KitKat
I don't like sped there's something
about the bed all right ma can open here
apparently oh this is a closet the
closets in the movie - [ __ ] it's not
good I'm learning to say [ __ ] stayed
here
Wow Oh [ __ ] kitty cat goddamnit
they always hot Oh double kitty gets
double I they double-team upon me that
sounded disgusting no no no no girl
don't go in the closet girl he likes to
paint what's the problem take up the key
that's right there thank you girl
thank you bro fish yay yay all right
fine
room key I don't know which room maybe
the one downstairs probably all right
let's go down there girl and barge and
keep cats yeah
keep getting comfy if you want if you're
saved kick at favorite video oh my honey
we're gonna crash I love sake you like
all the kid cats in horror games are Oh
No oh hey hey you came buddy that's nice
oh I like one too dad
hi doggy mate get back off dad
oh I got a snack it's a cod this is a
little bit all you want if you want to
fight you get
I'm just stupid you think I call right
all right all right [ __ ] cute all
right one kitty cat I said one cow know
I'm running out of batteries [ __ ] no
hello
all right we need to hurry hurry s
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I bet there's a battery in the room I
don't want to replay this [ __ ] hurry
hurry hurry girl can't you see you're
running out of batteries she's so stupid
I just want to go in the room and
[ __ ] least I heard this come on buddy
come on buddy don't don't let me down
buddy don't you dare [ __ ] light me
down I'll [ __ ] your mother and your
father
open open for the love of penis thank
you she has love opinions all right
hello please send me those [ __ ]
battery here oh no there's no balance Oh
uh-oh and you fun dude your battery oh
that was so on and so on and so on and
so on and so on so on so on so on so on
girls
oh [ __ ] pizza delivery oh no I'm gonna
die I don't wanna die I don't I I own
did I what I load news thing loan use it
now yeah all right all right that's fine
come on come on we have to make it a
battery come on buddy come on baby now I
keep running outta my slot too that's
why the queue all right I guess I will
have the privilege to replay
all right once again welcome back
oh wait no way that I did why dye that
why I that white okay okay okay I got it
ah um apparently I missed the door I
thought it was a window it's right over
he this is a door apparently I don't
really know how Japanese doors work but
alright hey what's [ __ ] I don't like
here gum oh wait this probably is home
that awkward bro bro not cool bro are
you gonna mail at me you're gonna mount
on me
of course you are obvious you've done it
entire game just get the [ __ ] out get
buy some [ __ ] clothes one-eyed King
maybe now I can go in here I can't go in
here now I'm gonna be alright get we can
go in here finally alright finalmente
loss Yama's
all right whatever hey don't place looks
expensive I'm stealing that too they
don't want to give you batteries in this
map for whatever reason I guess it's
kind of weird if you'd just scatter
batteries around the place this is a
door a window
she keeps popping up in my face I don't
like that oh [ __ ] your frickin frackin
fruit frickin frackin it through what is
this
this was like a battery - yes we're
saved all right all right it's cool let
me just figure out how to open come on
come on but I'm almost I'm we're happy
all right here we go
safe thing I'm saving like a
[ __ ] oh oh oh oh oh it's time to
shake you shaggy hey girl how you doing
up so you had your period likely oh oh
oh okay
okay it's cool it's cool actually a cold
you want to kiss me it's calm but you
know you breath you may want to take
them in first
ah goddamn it my dog is not the
waterfall ah god damn fine can I open
this door now about freaking girl
stratify
all right we get ya frigate if I can
good [ __ ] is about to go down in kitchen
boys and girls the doors closed by
itself I don't like that I really
[ __ ] need this battery I really
really
what does see cranes drifting that's
obnoxious
Oh Oh she has a knife oh she's chopping
her arm no bro
bro I don't like you bro that was
disgusting
she shouldn't be shopping her own arm
maybe then she'll get a penis can you
pick that up for me please thank you
it's a key I don't need a key I need a
flashlight are you kidding me oh she's
kidding me where's the flashlight bro
all right I'm actually on the end here
bro so I figured I'd love to do hope you
enjoyed like and favorite if you did
subscribe to come over and I'll see you
tomorrow all right ah ha ha
I got [ __ ] locked doors everywhere am
i walking these circles I'm alive it's
America
thank Satan haha back off [ __ ]